joining us on the line is miss demaris
misty's a trial attorney based in new
york specializing in the defense of
clients
and entertainment sports employment
civil rights and sexual assault and
abuse cases she of course was covering
the chauvin trial gavel the gavel for
hln misty mayor thanks for joining the
show appreciate it
thank you ben for having me i appreciate
being here first let's talk obviously
about the actual verdict so the verdict
came down incredibly fast
as soon as they said that it was coming
down yesterday afternoon
i immediately said guilty on all counts
because there's no way it was going to
be anything else obviously you require
unanimous verdicts for either acquittal
or for conviction in minnesota
there was no way they were going to quit
on all charges inside of 10 hours that
was just not going to happen
and if there had been any sort of debate
it would have been it would have gone to
the judge the judge would have told them
to go back to chambers
what is your reaction to the verdict
coming back this fast after a three-week
trial
ben i was actually so surprised that the
verdict came in i wasn't even prepared
and i was on verdict watch i was thought
to myself this is crazy i assumed
that we would hear some questions from
the jury very
often you hear the jury they want the
trial instructions the jury instructions
explained they need a little bit more
information more context
without one question from the jury i was
really surprised because look
this case had a lot of complicated
issues specifically the medical
testimony the causation
issue 10 hours seemed incredibly fast
but my gut was the same as yours been
when i heard that the verdict was in
i said okay guilty on all counts not
what i had expected but
certainly once that speed factor with no
questions
that was the result i anticipated under
those circumstances so misty frankly i
wasn't just stunned by the speed
uh because it was so fast it it does
to me raise questions about how
seriously the evidence was considered in
the case because this
i think that there was a a fairly strong
argument for manslaughter here at least
a decent too strong argument for
manslaughter i think that the the case
for beyond a reasonable doubt on third
degree murder is
insane frankly i think that the elements
of third degree murder did not even fit
to the extent that originally that was
not included in the charging documents
and then eventually it was replaced and
the case for second-degree murder
requires
a bunch of barriers to be passed the
fact that there was no questions
it's just not a clear enough case for me
to to feel like
the evidence was properly inspected by
the jury you can't get inside the jury
room but it does make me suspicious that
the that the amount of outside pressure
on this case
must have had some impact in the in the
thinking of the jury not that jurors
were intimidated but that
when you spend a year saying that this
is the most important criminal case in
modern american history
and then the jury comes back inside of
10 hours hard for me to believe that
they went in there did an objective
verification of the evidence really went
through each piece and examined it
inside of 10 hours and then came out
with a conviction on all accounts
yeah 10 hours is incredibly fast for for
that reason ben and yes the the evidence
was
incredibly complicated i agree with you
you know i really thought
that we might see a hung jury on all
counts and that's because of that
causation aspect i thought that was
really really murky and remember the
standard is beyond a reasonable doubt
the prosecution has to prove
every element of every charge beyond a
reasonable doubt so
to me i thought that there was a strong
possibility we would see a hung jury
i agree with you i actually thought the
prosecution's case if you can get over
that causation aspect
on manslaughter was pretty strong we're
talking about
a recklessness standard that is a lower
standard
of as far as intent than the other
charges require
for me with respect to the other two
charges the murder charges the highest
level charges
there was evidence there that look at
some point
this force was reasonable why do i know
that
i know that because the prosecution's
expert and the prosecution's witnesses
said so so to me that we're on a
spectrum here right and now the jury is
charged with determining
okay the force was reasonable up until
what point and when does it become
unreasonable to serve as the basis
for these other charges now when you're
on that spectrum
it becomes incredibly difficult to get
to that point where we say
oh there was an intentional assault here
or there was depraved
a depraved heart so i agree with you you
know i thought those charges were a
stretch but look the juries are
unpredictable i mean we all know that
anybody who covers trials knows that
piece of it
and also the jury can put weight uh more
weight towards some evidence more weight
towards some
testimony than others and clearly here
i mean my opinion i think the video
carried the day for this jury
however you bring up another great point
there are so many appellate issues here
that relate to what you said
whether or not this jury could be fair
and impartial
now look the defense had asked for
relief on this front
multiple times before and during the
trial first was asking for a change of
venue
the basis for a change of venue is can
this defendant
get a fair trial in this jurisdiction
now look
take the temperature of the area you've
got george floyd square
you've got the national guard the
courthouse is on lockdown
you've got businesses boarded up and
you're talking about pulling a jury pool
who's going to be impacted by this these
are members of this community
their businesses their homes their lives
could be seriously impacted and that
that really
needed to be part of the analysis of
that change of venue court said no
they said look it's publicity everywhere
you're not going to be anywhere in the
world and not know about this case
but that's really not where the inquiry
ends right because there's this other
aspect about whether or not jurors are
going to
feel that they can come back with
anything but guilty on all counts
so moving forward that the defense asked
for the jurors to be sequestered a
couple of times once at the beginning
uh and once when dante wright unrest
came came
out now the court said no i might have
asked for a mistrial at that point but
that's just me ben
uh and and of course those issues are
preserved on appeal right at the very
beginning during jury selection
a civil settlement of 27 million dollars
is announced
in the midst of jury selection two
jurors who were already sat
had to be dismissed because they were
biased or the court found that they
could be biased due to that settlement
and then of course more recently
we have what happened with maxine waters
a member of the executive branch
saying that a murder conviction is the
only
is the right conviction and and
otherwise there's going to be
consequences essentially that that you
get confrontational
i understand why eric nelson went in
there and said
i'm moving for a mistrial under these
circumstances because
it's becoming incredibly evident that
there are
outside factors that could be impacting
what happens inside the courtroom
now the judge said no but he did say and
this is the saltiest i saw cahill in
this whole case
he was very upset by the comments that
were happening outside of the courtroom
from government officials maxine waters
presumably later joe biden
regarding this trial because public
opinion
should have nothing to do with the jury
verdict the jurors are supposed to be
fair and unbiased
in that jury room deliberating on the
evidence that they saw in the courtroom
and nothing more you know
many prominent public officials have
come out since the verdict and have
openly said if we didn't have millions
of people in the street we don't reach
this verdict
which to me is is like game over as to
your entire argument
about bias in the criminal justice
system your entire argument is the
criminal justice system
is is corrupt and terrible and and that
in this case they got it right but the
only reason that they got it right in
this case is because we had people out
in the streets
that is the definition of how the
criminal justice system is supposed to
not work
is that they're not supposed to care
about there's millions of people in the
streets for any cause it's supposed to
be out the evidence
in this particular case for this
individual defendant
correct and and i'm a defense lawyer ben
so i take that to heart
the the the the state that our our
criminal justice system is based on
a defendant getting a fair trial it's
based on
the presumption of innocence it's based
on the prosecution's burden
to prove their case beyond a reasonable
doubt it's not
public opinion the notion that public
opinion
it's supposed to be a positive that
public opinion sways a jury
is actually terrifying to me because
again
what you need is for fair trials every
defendant needs to be treated
the same get a fair trial when they're
in that courtroom and the decision
by a jury a jury that takes their oath
seriously
needs to be based on the evidence that
comes into that courtroom
the elements of the case the
prosecution's burden to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt and again ben i have to
say it one more time
because again i this hits me close to
home as a defense lawyer
presumption of innocence that is the
cornerstone of our leadership
misty let me ask about the appeals
process here so uh
there would be great irony and chovin
being convicted on all charges only to
have the
the trial declared a mistrial because
because maxine waters decided to jet set
into minneapolis
and and ratchet up the tensions how does
the appeals process work
what are the prospects that something
actually happens here given the intense
public pressure surrounding the case i
can't
it's very difficult for me to imagine
that an appellate court simply decides
to declare a mistrial
after the most celebrated criminal
justice case in modern american history
and after you have full-scale open
celebration by the president and vice
president of the united states of the
verdict
yeah no and look ben it goes up it goes
up in in
to this appeals court in minnesota so
you know
there's certainly an element of it
that's going to be
it's in that venue it's in that
jurisdiction and courts
do appellate courts don't usually like
to overturn trial verdicts and that's on
any case so
you make some really good points if
they're doing their job the public
uh the public opinion is not a part of
the analysis look i think
the maxine waters comment that threw oil
on an already burning fire with respect
to appellate issues and they all have to
be looked at in the totality right
we can't just look at our comment and
say oh poo poo that we have to look at
in the context of what the defense had
requested
to ensure that the defendant did get a
fair trial and how that all played out
what the judge decided and whether or
not that is error judicial error that
can be overturned
now the analysis is based on whether or
not the result
would have been different whether it
would have had a meaningful impact on
the ultimate result
or the jury if something had been
different if one of these appellate
issues
uh is seen as as error so that's the
standard
it's not an easy standard but i would
submit to you
that there were other issues as well in
this case and they had to do with the
scope of some of the testimony
now the bystander witnesses again the
first question is are these witnesses
relevant and look they're bystanders
they're going to be relevant right it's
relevant to the case
but the next question is what about the
scope of their testimony observations
that they saw okay
but these questions about how did that
make you feel
i'm a new york lawyer they say we're
feisty i would be doing jumping jacks in
the courtroom
objection that has nothing to do with
the case and the analysis is prohibitive
value
which means facts that are going to lead
to evidence or evidence that's going to
lead to you know
facts in the case or versus prejudice
so probative versus prejudice and
probative is supposed to be higher
probative has it has to be more
probative than prejudicial
and to ask these young kids 17 year olds
and nine year old
you know the clerk of the store it was
emotional the in the prosecution's case
was largely emotional and i i would say
it was impactful
certainly on television and probably to
a jury but i submit to you
and our listeners and if i'm drafting
this appeal
i'm focused on the fact that that was
just so far outside of the scope
of what is relevant and so highly
prejudicial
that it would be error that that needs
to be revisited on appeal and i just
want to make it clear
i'm not saying the jury got it wrong i
personally don't feel that i'm in a
position to say
what's right or wrong because again
public opinion my opinion that doesn't
matter
but but the the cornerstone of our
democracy the cornerstone of our legal
system
is a fair trial and all of these issues
absolutely need to be addressed
in the appeals process and see where
that goes
you flagged some concerns again if
judges are doing what they're supposed
to do
they are to look at this through the
lens of
what is correct under the legal
standards without respect to what's
going on in the public and that is miss
dimaris you can check her out she's been
doing
derek chauvin trial coverage for hln and
she of course is an attorney based in
new york city misty thanks so much for
analysis really appreciate it
thank you ben we're in a battle for the
culture and for our values
like and subscribe to help keep our
videos on the front line of the fight
and top of your feed